I'm sitting at the airport and they have all this NFL pregame going on and I'm
thinking of, fuck,
I'm gonna Miss Everything and I'm watching the pregame and which I never watch
and I haven't really watched it in years.
It's why I don't know anybody's names anymore. And I'm really bad at that.
I mean part of it's cause I'm on the road all the fucking time. But uh,
I think, um, I dunno. Sorry guys.
Can you tell him looking at something else here on the computer? I,
so I'm sitting there watching it and uh,
the first thing I see and I started tweeting this shit and it kind of started,
uh,
I got a little thing going on Twitter of just the dumb shit that they say in the
whole fucking um, the NFL pregame. Okay.
You'll like freeze tape right there. Okay. Will you she right there.
What are you each making decision?
He is making decisions and that is a good thing. He's looking good.
He's not all you. Last year he was just looking, it was just first rate.
He was telegraphing where he was going to throw the ball. And if you,
she right here, what he's doing, he is now checking down the field.
It's chicken in third read.
Now I can tell you when a quarterback judge that there is,
when he's doing to play the quarterback position and [inaudible]
film level, right? Fucking all of that shit.
Just a bunch of fucking people in suits breaking down the game the way it never
needed to be broken down.
It is completely a product of fucking 9,024 hour sports channels.
I mean, dude, I'm sitting there,
it's like two and a half hours before kickoff and they're already doing pregame.
It's like, dude,
pregame used to be a half hour before Brent Musburger,
Irv Cross, that Kennedy woman, whatever the hell.
Jackie can't not Jackie Kennedy. What the hell was the name? Um,
and then Jimmy, the Greek, that was CBS and NBC.
You had fucking Brian Gumbel and Mike,
Adam Lee NFL 81 right? That's what the fuck do you do?
That's all.
You just watched that and they went around the league and it was cool. Bang,
Bang, boom. And you were done and then you went to your local feed.
Now you just got these guys who are out there,
they're are acting it out on that half a football field
over and far.
Tell you right now what they're trying to do is you're trying to turn around the
culture in the locker, your own the locker room for years. It is,
it has been a mentality that we are not gonna win the big one.
And that's why they brought in Joe fucking bag of donuts to come in and cray
playground. But it's stupid shit ever
over and fucking over and over. So anyway, so I go, I get on the,
I started tweeting all of that shit and uh, you know,
just making up player names and all that dumb shit that they said, right?
He's a changed man. He came in niche,
he came into camp in the best shape of his football life.
He's the two, his coaches,
he is it his wife and he only tested positive to weed. And I'll tell you that
type attitude,
that type attitude is you could change your shit in the locker room.
How many fucking times do they even sit there rolling their eyes with if their
football speak drives me up the fucking wall.
Yeah.
Oh. Anyway.
She [inaudible] he needs to do is he needs to feel the pass rush you have to in
the national football league,
which you have to be able to do is feel when that pocket is collapsing around
you. You've gotta have a clock in your head.
You gotta have a clock in your head and you don't want what it's clicking down.
You have to know, you must get rid of the football. Cause I tell you right now,
if you don't do that and you take a sack right there,
that that is a drive killer, Mike.
Oh absolutely. Absolutely. I absolutely agree. What he's doing here is you go,
he's parenting a ball. He's telegraphing his parishes.
This is the type of stuff that they worked on in the off season.
He showed some promising moments in the preseason, but I go tell you today,
I don't know where that was in an I got to you. I've got to wonder, is it
you hit the panic button down chaplain,
who the fuck can sit there and watch that horse?
And then what I love is sports fans watch that shit and then it gets,
it's like a virus and then it gets in their fucking heads and then they go out
to sports bars and you talk about football and then they start sounding like
those people.
Okay,
Yo try. You know Joe, you gotta have a fucking clock in your head, kid.
One, 1002,
1000 fucking get rid of it. Throw it out of botch.
Joe, you're allowed to do that.
As long as you're within the confines you the fucking pocket.
I can't, I can't fucking, I can't go to sports bars.
Why would you? I don't give a fuck how fucking broke you are.
There was no reason to not have the NFL package. There isn't. Alright,
you can go 40 fucking days without food. As long as you got water, you're fine.
Do yourself a fucking favor. Starve yourself and yes.
Okay.
I'm advocating Anorexia to get the NFL package to not go down
to the fucking sports bar eating that heart attack food.
Okay,
watch it. A bunch of grown men walking around in jerseys like they're dated,
dating the fucking player doing it all day,
Dan. Horse Shit.
You gotta go down there looking at those tired waitresses join a whore it up and
they're fucking cutoff ref shirt
listening to that bullshit. Unbelievable.
At time to make a change. I'll tell you, I ain't,
have I been up the I am if I am the [inaudible] of court now, who's had,
you've got to
understand with this kid,
this kid is 19 offensive coordinators and the last seven seasons.
Okay, I still don't take that. We have,
see what this kid is able to do up there. I'm still holding on. Yeah,
but you have to on your skin. Did he hear head Achy, hinge?
I don't know. I can't. I can't fuck. Right, right, right.
I'm annoying myself just, just even listening to this shit.
Well Joey, you get all these teams, they know each other.
They meet twice a year. Each team. They know what they do.
When a Toyo tell you, I know it's hard to be team two times one season out day,
right? Your Baba football fan. I gotta be looking to that first matchup. Oh,
these Seattle Seahawks against those share Francesco 49ers.
Can you 40 niners get over the hump? I mean, this is the question.
I mean there's rumors that Jim Harbaugh is losing the locker room.
Okay. How can you sit and watch that? Because anyways, I'll tell you new way.
I can tell you I love it. You know what?
I'll give you my predictions for week two. Okay.
Week two pregame football analysis.
And now off to New England where a shock legally last week they lost the size of
Lee. So these Miami Dolphins of the dolphin,
Miami County de Wade fucking area code, I'll tell you right now, I mean,
what do you think's going to happen when they come in and they play the a the
fucking the fucking Austin city.
I should topes what do you think's going to happen?
Well, I'll tell you right now. Oh, you know what I mean? You'll be, look,
we all know what Tom Brady could do. We all know bill bell. A check is a genius,
but I'll tell you right now, I mean,
I mean you get the talent or no channel and I mean you gotta be,
you gotta be concerned about that second half. I mean, hey,
I want a life less out there. It's going to be a lot of that shit.
Yeah.
I mean, if they lose today, they're all in to [inaudible] road sugar.
Like,
like I couldn't be doing that for a fucking hour,
not for an hour. They'll do it for a little bit and then they're gonna.
I don't know what the fuck else they're going to talk about.
I see the world through my team and I know that they're going to be doing that
shit.
Or you can just skip all of that and you can go fucking workout at the gym,
right?
Go for a hike with your fucking dog or something and you can come back.
The wonderful world of fucking DVR, you can come back an hour before the game,
after the game started. You can just plow through all the fucking halftime,
everything and just get right to the third quarter, right?
Let your wife watch the real housewives during the first half,
you know, and you just make, before you go out to the gym, you just say,
listen sweetheart, you grab up by a handful of hair, the back of her head.
You feel that shit. If you fucking shut off the recording, I swear to God,
I'm going to have you live under the coffee tables. No joking. I'm joking.
Blogger worlds.